lp elle continue avec le match des idées
confrontation de points de vue ce soir
entre christian makarian nicolas tenzer
plusieurs sujets internationaux vont
nous occuper est d'abord ce retour des
frontières au sein de l'europe depuis ce
mardi l'allemagne impose des tests des
autorisations à sa frontière avec la
moselle ce qui de fait revient à fermer
son pays à la france le kobe tu viens de
faire sauter un tabou majeur au sein de
l'europe et surtout au sein du couple
franco allemand
on va en parler avec nos invités juste
après le rappel des faits avec jean dan
klein
des dizaines de camions bloqués entre
l'allemagne et la pologne ou encore les
avions à l'aéroport d'orly à la rainette
il y a tout juste un an
l'épidémie frappe l'union européenne et
oblige les gouvernements à fermer quasi
totalement les frontières aujourd'hui
l'épidémie toujours bien présente et les
pays de l'union européenne ajustent leur
réponse après avoir fermé sa frontière à
une partie de l'autriche et à la
république tchèque l'allemagne impose
désormais un test pcr négatif aux
personnes en provenance de moselle les
frontières qui ce faire ne sont pas une
solution la solution c'est de réguler en
fait au maximum cette épidémie quand
c'est nécessaire par des confinement
localisées qui soient forts mais qu'ils
soient courts simplement pour éviter des
situations déraperait et donc bloquer
les frontières là ça veut dire bloqué la
circulation au sein d'une même métropole
au sens démographique et économique
une logique que dénonce la commission
européenne qui craint la tentation du
chacun pour soi
depuis l'arrivée des nouveaux variants
certains pays européens imposent des
restrictions plus ou moins drastiques
aux voyageurs comme l'angleterre la
belgique le danemark ou l'allemagne plus
récemment la volonté je m'en félicite
d'avoir un esprit franco-allemand
coopératif d'éviter de revenir à ce
qu'on a vécu douloureusement au
printemps dernier où il y avait des
fermetures de frontières des contrôles à
la frontière un peu partout entre la
france et l'allemagne
je souscris à la volonté de l'autriche
et leur budget que leur dispositif celui
des allemands à leur égard souhaite
alléger
d'ailleurs la commission européenne sont
et émules puisque les allemands vont au
delà du cadre qu'on a agréé au niveau
européen je crois qu'il faut donner
l'exemple pour tenter d'harmoniser les
mesures entre les 27 la commission
européenne va présenter durant le mois
de mars un projet de passeport vaccinale
commun l'objectif permettre de voyager à
travers l'espace schengen et tenter de
sauver la saison estivale avec nous pour
le match des idées ce soir christian
makarian bienvenue aux et éditorialiste
de politique internationale et nicolas
tenzer bienvenue à vous également osé
politologue président du centre d'étude
et de réflexion pour l'action politique
et directeur de la revue le bon ok merci
à tous les deux c'est quand même fort
symboliquement nicolas tenzer ce que
vient de faire l'allemagne d'imposer ces
tests à la frontière avec la moselle
c'est un cap qui est franchie c'est un
cap
oui c'est à dire que là quand même à
partir du moment où les états européens
s'étaient dit on se coordonne nous
sommes tous ensemble nous prenons des
mesures conjointes tout à coup de
manière unilatérale on a un état qui dit
voilà on termine non ferme y compris
pour comme les trolls et les
travailleurs frontaliers pour les
quelques soldats ils ont presque un but
et je sais que ça avait ressenti comme
ça enfin quand on voit la communication
aussi bien du président que du
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes clément bonne on voit que
vraiment ils ont été un peu pris par
surprise et c'est vrai qu'entre alliés
européens
ça semblait quand même assez assez
anormal quelles que soient les raisons
sanitaires évidemment qui pousse
l'allemagne à faire sens mais quelles
que soient les raisons sanitaires elles
sont quand même importante ces raisons
sanitaires ya une urgence sanitaire ce
qu'on peut lui en vouloir à l'allemagne
de vouloir protéger son pays sa
population et je crois que tout ce qui
est frappant dans cette crise c'est
l'émergence du facteur politique de
politique intérieure madame merkel de
toute évidence joue avec les länder et
en fonction de leur position
géographique
on l'a vu avec dans la jonction avec le
tyrol autrichien où il ya aussi des
mesures très coercitives et respectives
voilà merkel joue avec
les institutions allemandes telles
qu'elles sont c'est-à-dire un pouvoir
central qui doit le disputait à des
pouvoirs régionaux aux länder est donc
en ce qui concerne la zone de contact
avec la france d'autant plus que madame
merkel veut faire passer des mesures
d'assouplissement
bientôt elle a un agenda le rendez vous
le 8 mars avec les länder
donc elle est obligée de composer et je
pense que tout ça est fortement teinté
de politique intérieure mais est ce que
ça peut entacher l'amitié franco
allemand de voir un peu abîmé cette
europe où on s'aperçoit que c'est un peu
l'air du repli sur soi du chacun pour
soi je pense que sur l'amitié franco
allemands n'ont en tout cas il y aurait
peut-être d'autres facteurs qui
pourraient peser à l'avenir
voilà ça ça va dépendre évidemment aussi
des élections septembre prochain en
allemagne
tout ceci va être déterminant en
revanche sur le fond quand on voit la
stratégie aussi vaccinale séparer d'un
certain nombre d'états notamment la
hongrie notamment la slovaquie qui
décide d'acheter des vaccins russes
voire peut-être même un jeu chinois etc
là on a quand même quelque chose qui est
vraiment une tâche dans cette union de
l'europe et je pense que là il ya un
vrai sujet de cohésion surtout qu'on a
quand même un plan qui a été décidée qui
a été avalisé par l'ensemble des états
qui étaient poussés par la commission on
peut critiquer sur un certain nombre de
choses sans doute mais quand même là je
pense que c'est un front désuni qui pour
le coup est extrêmement extrêmement
dangereux parce que derrière aussi ses
stratégies vaccinales d'état vous voyez
bien qu'il ya des influences d'autres
états notamment bien sûr de la russie
pour la hongrie
voire pour la slovaquie qui te sont
quand même des facteurs de division qui
font peser quand même sur le destin de
l'europe
on parle beaucoup de robes puissance
d'autonomie stratégique de l'europe et
candé et à se tourner vers d'autres
puissances je pense que ça c'est quand
même très dommageable la crise qu il est
en train de mettre à l'épreuve notre en
tout cas elle est en train de démontrer
qu un buzz
urgent de souveraineté médical de
souveraineté européenne et d'une
politique de santé commune puisque
encore une fois il faut toujours le
rappeler
beaucoup de gens ne sont pas informés de
ce fait nos traité ne prévoit pas que la
politique de santé soit une compétence
commune partagée par tous les états mans
il est question d'un dans un article de
coordination des politiques de santé
l'un traité dans un article seulement
mais ça ne fait pas partie de la
stratégie globale
deuxièmement un des principes
fondamentaux et fondateur de l'union
européenne c'est la liberté de
circulation
c'est essentiel et bien cette liberté
circulation semble aujourd'hui beaucoup
souffrir de la crise de lakovic 19 et
c'est en soi une remise en cause des
fondements des fondements de l'ordre
parce que c'est un principe essentiel et
qui a réussi sur la base du président
bien sûr qui a réussi à l'europe voire
tout cela aujourd'hui régressé ce serait
très dommageable alors c'est pas
dramatique si on remplace encore une
fois si on en profite pour franchir un
cran est passé à une souveraineté
médicale européenne d'une part et à une
politique de santé comme une compétence
commune
on sait donc que c'est donc la prochaine
étape et il faut à mon avis nourrir ce
débat l'europe est l'épreuve du coc vide
on passe au deuxième thème de ce match
messieurs on en vient à cet appel pour
le rapatriement des enfants français et
de leur mère emprisonnée en syrie il est
signé de deux parlementaire du sénateur
communiste pierre laurent et du député
udf pierre morel à l'huissier notre
journaliste et les nomme berkaoui a pu
interviewer pierre laurent sur
publicsenat.fr vous l'avez vu et pour
lui
vu la dégradation des conditions dans
les camps syrien le gouvernement ne peut
plus attendre pour rapatrier ses
ressortissants
avant d'en parler avec vous on va
accueillir dans ce match des idées un
autre sénateur engagée sur le sujet
c'est jean yves le conte bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur socialiste représentant
les français établis hors de france
vous êtes d'accord avec pierre laurent
l'exécutif doit absolument urgent
mon rapidement rapatrier ses
ressortissants et notamment donc ces
enfants et ces femmes retenues en syrie
absolument je le peux je pouvais
reprendre toutes les toutes les toutes
les lignes de bus du courrier de pierre
laurent sur le sujet d'abord compte tenu
de la situation humanitaire de ddd ont
peu à peu près 300 enfants qui sont qui
sont concernés ain j'appelle de ce sont
des des jeunes enfants souvent nés sur
site donc qui n'a absolument aucune
responsabilité dans dans la situation et
d'autre part aussi pour des raisons
sécuritaires la même les des
spécialistes de l'antiterrorisme et
compte tenu de la dégradation de la
situation sur place
on ne peut pas se permettre de continuer
à fermer les yeux sur ce drame
humanitaire qui représente en même temps
parce que pour pour ce pour prôner les
camps qui sont sur les territoires
contrôlés par les kurdes en syrie est
aujourd'hui un vrai un vrai danger
compte tenu de la dégradation sur place
de la situation
j'arrive le comte pierre laurent parle
aussi d'un blocage politique j'imagine
que vous reprenez là aussi à votre
compte cette expression qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que vous sentez que le sujet
est trop brûlant que ce n'est pas assez
populaire au sein de l'opinion pour que
les lignes bougent et que l'exécutif ne
fera rien il n'y a aucune raison
rationnelle de ne pas bouger sur ce
sujet il n'y a aucune raison humanitaire
de ne pas bouger sur ce sujet
la seule raison qui explique
l'immobilisme c'est le fait que auprès
de la population ce n'est pas populaire
voilà c'est un manque de courage un
manque de courage à la fois j'ai dire
politique et humain de la part de
l'exécutif que de laisser cette
situation pourrir
alors que je rappel il s'agit de 250 à
300 enfants qui ont moins de 6 ans et
que compte tenu de la situation sur
place nous avons nous ne pouvons pas
nous permettre la finlande semble-t-il à
la fed autres pays européens
d'autres pays ont rapatrié leurs sols et
les
qui était sur site parce que il
considérait que c'était leur
responsabilité et je dirais en ce qui
concerne les mères de ses enfants
on ne peut pas se permettre quand la
situation se dégrade de les laisser sur
site et de devenir finalement d'un
nouveau danger pour le pays vaudrait
mieux qu'aujourd'hui elle puisse être
judiciariser en france et qu'elles
répondent de leurs actes
en france plutôt que qu'on les laisse
surveillé par les kurdes dans des
conditions qui sont très mauvaise passe
qu'il ne peut rien faire d'autre
et en plus alors qu'ils ont il doit
faire face aussi à une résurgence de
l'état islamique pierre laurent espère
qu'au mois de mars vous serez plusieurs
dizaines de parlementaires a exigé le
retour de ses ressortissants français
vous vous sentez que le sujet est en
train de prendre au sénat où est ce que
là aussi il ya du blocage politique
je crois que nous serons nombreux jeunes
je ne pense pas que je ne suis pas du
tout certain que nous serons
majoritaires nous serons nombreux et il
faudra vraiment insister à la fois sur
les questions humanitaires que que cela
pose mais aussi sur finalement le fait
de repousser à demain avec de nouveaux
risques
une situation sécuritaire qui s'aggrave
sur place et on ne peut pas se permettre
de laisser des ressortissantes qui qui
pourrait représenter un danger si elle
n'était pas ont récupéré en france et
judiciariser en france mais vraiment
deux aspects ya il ya un risque les
maires peuvent représenter un risque il
faut qu'elle soit judiciariser et les
enfants c'est une situation humanitaire
y en avait énormément qui sont morts y
en a qui ont des difficultés de santé
majeur ils sont dans des situations
horribles
on ne peut pas se permettre de fermer
les yeux sur finalement des
ressortissants français
quel que soit ce qu'ont fait leurs
parents jean yves le conte je vous
propose de rester avec nous on va
évidemment faire réagir nos invités en
plateau christian makarian pierre
laurent nous dit le pouvoir exécutif est
en train de sacrifier des enfants à
l'aune d'un calendrier électoral est ce
que ça vous semble juste écoutez moi il
me semble que il y a
un aspect tout à fait biaisé dans ce
débat on laisse l'impression et je
comprends très bien les objectifs
humanitaires que poursuit monsieur le
sénateur mais en laisse l'impression à
l'opinion que ce problème a été créée
par les pays occidentaux
or c'est le fruit patients méthodique et
résolue de la propagande de dèche sont
en sommes là parce que des shows
justement voit une continuité dans son
objectif d'affaiblissement des pays
occidentaux voient une sorte de
continuité a provoqué ce débat entre
l'humanitaire et le sécuritaire et il ya
là quelque chose qui contribue encore à
déstabiliser dans l'esprit des
djihadistes à déstabiliser les
démocraties occidentales ont choix qu'il
faut quand même le rappeler ce n'est pas
nous qui avons créé ce problème
ce sont ces femmes qui ont fait ses
choix et qui ensuite ont engendré sur
place et sacré le problème que l'on sait
maintenant il y avait une solution qu'on
a esquissé onusienne une solution
internationale qui n'a pas abouti et ça
il faut le regretter
c'est à dire de créer des instances de
tri et de prise en charge de ces
populations qui sont les enfants ou leur
mère par des responsables internationaux
et les organisations internationales
après une phase évidemment juridiques
préalables et convenablement mené ça n'a
pas abouti alors résultat on se retrouve
avec effectivement la situation qui est
très bien et est décrite par le sénateur
mais est ce que il est décent et il est
raisonnable d'aller contre l'opinion
publique parce que l'opinion publique et
de façon écrasante est majoritaire tout
à l'heure monsieur sénateur vous citiez
le cas de la finlande qui a repris
effectivement sérieuse qui a reçu et qui
a réintégré ses ressortissants nationaux
mais on peut citer juste à côté le cas
de la norvège où il ya eu un impact
politique très néfaste rennes pouvoir en
place et sait pas si thomas
le gouvernement va des élections étaient
perdus et le gouvernement était affaibli
pour avoir poursuivi la même politique
donc il a dû renoncer
donc il y a quand même des impacts et un
fonctionnement démocratique dont il veut
tenir compte
les populations ne veulent pas que l'on
traite cette affaire de cette façon là
alors le quai d'orsay a inventé la
fameuse formule du cas par cas
prenons les dossiers un par an regardons
les enfants leur ascendance la position
de la mer le degré d'urgence médicale et
on a réintégré en france il faut aussi
le rappeler trente cinq jeunes enfants
à ce jour moi je ne suis pas assez
informés pour savoir quel est le suivi
scolaire psychologique médical
sécuritaire même de ces enfants qui sont
en train de mentir sur le sol national
et ça mériterait qu'on le fasse
connaître davantage il faut qu'on soit
un peu plus rigoureux et ne pas manier à
mon avis simplement des principes post
rousseauiste l'enfance re est totalement
innocent et le réintégrer règlerait tous
les problèmes ce n'est pas vrai ça
poserait d'autres types de problèmes il
faut donc des structures si on décide de
le faire en france très fine très adapté
psychologues éducateurs tout suivi
absolument méthodique
c'est quelque chose que les démocraties
n'ont jamais eu affaire au préalable
jamais palace avec quelques années
qu'elle aurait pu s'y préparer je vous
laisse répondre peut-être jean yves le
conte je vous ai vus prendre des notes
de j'imagine que vous avez envie de
répondre à christian makarian oui tout à
fait parce qu'il ya un aspect sur lequel
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui
c'est que ce n'est pas simple de d'avoir
des structures d'accueil de ses enfants
adapté j'allais dire parce que si on
pense que c'est avec les ont ils
retournent chez leurs grands parents les
grands parents c'est les parents de ceux
qui sont partis en syrie donc à une
difficulté
donc ça je partage avec lui par contre
je refuse absolument et je suis
profondément choqué de cette dialectique
de ces sois l'humanitaire sur la
sécurité que nous vous qu'est ce que
vous nous direz demain monsieur ma
carrière s'il ya un attentat parce
qu'une femme qui aurait été laissée dans
les camps de pêche plutôt d'être
judiciariser en france revient en france
de manière clandestine effet un attentat
les deux sont liés oui les deux sont
liés l'humanitaire dans ce domaine là
surtout quand il s'agit d'enfants de
paix qui n'ont aucune responsabilité
mais l'humanitaire et la judiciarisation
des femmes des mères de ces enfants est
une question de sécurité au maître c'est
c'est c'est clair dans les mains de la
justice française le plus rapidement
possible à partir de man une âme n'est
pas une solution
c'est une semaine où situer sur une
exigence de sécurité majeur mais
monsieur le sénat non vous savez très
bien que un certain nombre de ces maires
se sont radicalisées à l'intérieur des
camps et que là où je vous rejoins sans
doute vous n'en avez pas parlé mais je
suis sûr vous serez d'accord avec moi
c'est que la situation humaine et
humanitaire de ces corps est
inadmissible
donc on devrait absolument ans devrait
au lieu de meunier se débat avec des
grands principes avant tout assurer des
conditions décentes médicalement
humainement éducative dans ces camps
parce qu'à l'heure actuelle nous savons
très bien que des shows vous l'avez
signalé vous même refait surface à
travers plusieurs fois sporadiques et
que des femmes à l'intérieur de ces
corps pourchasse d'autres femmes
qu'elles jugent trop modéré et qu'il ya
une tentative de re radicalisation il ya
même eu il ya même eu des meurtres des
règlements je vous laisse répondre à une
seconde mais cette impatience
et c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut que
nous prenions la responsabilité de la
suite
nous ne pouvons pas là sous traitée aux
kurdes qui ont bien d'autres difficultés
aujourd'hui et en particulier celle de
lutter conte sur le terrain contre des
shu nicolas tenzer oui je pense qu'il ya
effectivement un vrai sujet qui est le
fait que l'on n'a pas traiter ce
problème assez tôt c'est à dire qu'on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une situation
qui est complètement empoisonné sur deux
points
bull part effectivement les enfants
effectivement ces enfants ne sont pas
responsables des crimes de leurs parents
ça c'est parfaitement clair il faut le
reconnaître que deuxièmement
l'humanitaire et le sécuritaire sont
complètement liés parce que ces enfants
qui auront été abandonnée demain qu'est
ce qu'ils vont devenir
ils vont être eux mêmes sans doute rang
pointent des phénomènes de rats
réalisation ils seront influencés ils
sont repris en charge auront une haine
encore accrue en quelque sorte pour
l'occident qui va être exploité par les
mouvements terroristes et partage pour
ça on ne peut pas à mon avis laissés là
et s'en désintéresser en ce qui concerne
effectivement les parents notamment les
maires mais dans certains cas c'est le
père moi je pense qu'effectivement
laisser ces personnes jugées quand elles
sont jugées par des gens que ce soit les
kurdes que ce soit d'autres groupes et c
est totalement irresponsable parce que
indépendamment de la question je dirais
humanitaire lui fait qu'on peut pas
accepter que d'autres appliquent la
peine de mort même si ces crimes qu'ils
ont pu commettre peuvent être évidemment
et authier pouvant table laisse quand
même
nous sommes contre la peine de mort il
faut le rappeler mais sait aussi que
quand même ces prisons on sait quand ce
sont des passoires
c'est à dire que après on va voir des
gens d'ailleurs c'est déjà arrivé des
gens qui se sont échappées de cet
endroit et qui se retrouvent dans la
nature et qui en termes de sécurité pour
nous et pour les pays occidentaux sont
encore plus dangereux finalement et je
pense que ça il fallait affronter ce
problème il fallait effectivement
christian me l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
sans doute le traité un niveau européen
et international
parce qu'effectivement il ya des
problèmes il ya le sujet de l'opinion et
on sait très bien que les rapatriés chez
nous avec des jeux indique ce national
s'est pas totalement aisée mais là aussi
on a refusé de poser le problème
sérieusement et on est notamment la
france quand je regrette que la france
n'ait pas pris l'initiative de lancer
vraiment une proposition sur le plan
international pour que la justice
internationale soient saisis de ces
personnes et je pense que c'était la
bonne solution
troisième remarque très rapidement il ya
quand même des expériences réussies vous
savez les enfants soldats et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants soldats en afrique et
il ya eu des expériences tout à fait
remarquable de réintégration de ces
enfants soldats
enfin soldats qui avaient participé à
des combats qui avaient eux mêmes
d'ailleurs participé à des massacres qui
avaient massacré qui avait tué et qu'on
a pu réintégrer dont je pense que il y a
quand même des expériences à succès il
faudrait peut-être aussi savoir sont
inspirés on s'arrêtera là sur ce sujet
merci infiniment j'allume le content
d'avoir participé à ce match des idées
je vois que le sujet passionne et
on y consacrera tout un débat je vous
promets de vous faire revenir sur ce
plateau mont à d'autres thèmes merci
infiniment j'arrive le contourner aussi
à quelques jours d'une visite historique
en irak du pape
c'est un déplacement majeur très
important a dit pape émérite benoît 16
dans un quotidien italien
je crois que c'est un voyage très
important dit-il malheureusement il
tombe à un moment très difficile qui
rend aussi son voyage dangereux pour des
raisons de sécurité et à cause du coc
vide et puis il ya la situation
irakienne instable j'accompagnerai
françois avec mes prières at il dit un
voyage important mais dangereux
christian makarian oui parce que la
situation en irak est plus instable que
jamais elle est depuis 2003 on sait très
bien et l'intervention américaine mais
il ya désormais clairement une un
déchirement entre un pouvoir qui verse
du côté de l'iran l'iran exerce évident
une influence très importante auprès de
la majorité chiite de la population et
de groupes armés très redoutable
et puis de l'autre côté on essaie
notamment les européens on a reçu
récemment les autorités irakiennes à
paris on essaie de maintenir une voie
plus modérés qui soit susceptible de
ceux de s'écarter de l'iran mais pour
revenir la visite du pack du pape
stricto sensu
l'enjeu essentiel c'est de démontrer
pour le pape qu' il existe en irak en
syrie au liban
autrefois un peu aussi en en iran en
tout cas aussi en jordanie dans presque
tous les pays du moyen-orient et a
fortiori en egypte avec 10% de coptes il
existe une minorité qu'on appelle les
chrétiens dans un volet chrétiens
d'orient par par abus de langage qui
recouvre
un grand nombre d'églises très
différenciée mais dans lesquels un
élément essentiel doit être rappelée
l'islamisme et toutes les théories qui
en découle que ce soit la branche des
frères musulmans les salafistes ou
d'autres ont pour objectif d'effacer
toutes formes de diversité et de dire
que l'islam c'est l'histoire et
l'histoire s'est dit cela il n'ya rien
au milieu et ce que veut démontrer le
pape sait que et une grande période
assez fastueuse de l'histoire de l'irak
le califes abbassides où les chrétiens
ont été respectées toléré il avait même
des droits réduits inférieur mais il
avait tout de même certains droits et
que le monde arabe est issu de cette
diversité est ce qui a fait sa gloire et
sa splendeur à certains moments ce fut
cette diversité cela que vient rappeler
le paris sg incorpore aussi les juifs
qui faisait partie également de ce
système là tu as donc c'est ça que va
rappeler le pape c'est attention si vous
détruisez cette diversité et s'il n'ya
que l'islam dans un pays arabe
ça n'est plus le sens de l'histoire
c'est une régression et de ce point de
vue là il faut défendre les chrétiens
d'orient
pas seulement parce que c'est une
minorité menacée mais parce que ça
concerne le souvenir le devenir de la
majorité c'est à dire que si on est une
civilisation diverses ou sur une
civilisation qui détruit la diversité on
va vers deux options radicalement
différente
or l'islamisme veut sous toutes ses
formes éliminer la diversité en
particulier universités chrétiennes faut
savoir que les chrétiens d'irak sont
parfois plus arabe que ne le sont
d'autres types d'autres parties de la
population et qui sont aussi anciens et
même antérieur très nettement antérieure
de plusieurs cercles de plusieurs
siècles à l'islam donc ça fait partie du
monde arabe et de la culture arabe que
d'être chrétien ces trois jours un acte
symbolique fort mais c'est aussi jeudi
réunit de la barre du pape une volonté
de montrer qu'il ne se désintéresse
absolument pas de cette région parce qu'
il n'est pas question pour le pape je
crois dans agonise et les communautés
justement pas et je pense que c'est là
la grande difficulté du message que
françois va devoir faire passer c'est de
dire voilà il ya cette minorité qu'il
faut évidemment défendre il faut pas la
défendre non plus uniquement parce
qu'ils sont chrétiens mais aussi parce
que c'est un apport à la civilisation
c'est tout à fait évident mais aussi
parce que c'est aussi un facteur de
stabilité d'un facteur très important
c'est un facteur de deux lieux de
culture que ces gens appartiennent au
pays mais surtout ne les oppose ont pas
je dirais aux musulmans et je pense que
c'est très simple d'autant plus
important que dans d'autres pays voisins
je pense en syrie on a eu de la part du
pouvoir une instrumentalisation de cette
communauté
alors même on le sait c'est le cas
évidemment d'assad qu'assad a profité en
quelque sorte soutien de quelques-uns au
sommet pour aussi aux primes et une
autre minorité des chrétiens je pense
qu'il faut surtout pas rentrer dans ce
type de débat en disant les chrétiens ce
sont les bons les autres ce sont les
méchants n'ont justement pareil je pense
que ça aussi c'est un message que le
pape devra faire passer parce que sinon
effectivement il va se trouver du côté
d'une minorité il va antagonisent et un
conflit qui a vraiment pas besoin de
l'être on par le vatican d'une main
tendue d'ailleurs à l'islam chiite
il nous reste trois minutes on va avoir
le temps rapidement de parler du de ce
dernier thème dimanche soir donald trump
qui a prononcé son premier discours
officiel d' exprès
10dans l'occasion de faire comprendre à
ses adversaires qu'il n'en avait pas
tout à fait fini avec lui et côté ils
n'arrêtent pas de dire il va créer un
tout nouveau parti nous avons le parti
républicain il va s'unir et être plus
fort que jamais je n'ai pas créé un
nouveau parti c'était une écluse fake
news
non ce ne serait pas génial commençons
un nouveau parti divison notre vote pour
que vous puissiez jamais gagné non ça
nous intéresse pas nous un président
républicain fera un retour triomphal à
la maison blanche
et je me demande qui ce sera nicolas
tenzer c'est une promesse de retour pour
la prochaine élection présidentielle
faut l'interpréter comme ça où on
extrapole un peu quand on veut goûter en
tout cas il est clair que que trump
envie de se représenter en 2024 il est
quand même dans une sorte de soif de
revanche il veut prendre sa revanche
c'est tout à fait évident et aussi il
est sous une forme aussi de haine
c'est ça qui est très frappant parce
qu'il faut voir qu'à cette fameuse
convention il a désigné ses adversaires
internes ou se dit à un moment il les a
nommés il est voilà tout certains qui
avaient voté effectivement voté lynch
min comme les chalets la fille de dick
cheney mais aussi un certain nombre
d'autres qui à certains moments la vesle
avait entre guillemets trahit un de son
point de vue et donc c'est aussi très
dangereux parce que ça veut dire qu'il
va porter vers l'extrême droite
peillon clair ce parti républicain
uniquement parce que on a eu quand même
un certain nombre de sénateurs la
majorité malheureusement qui n'ont pas
su lui tenir tête et donc aujourd'hui on
a un parti républicain plus malade que
jamais c'est quand même ça de la réalité
et ça c'est très inquiétant
est ce qu'il ne pourrait pas lasser à
force parce qu'ils emploient toujours
aussi les mêmes techniques à un fake
news du name and shame enfin tout ça est
ce que cette technique est toujours la
même c'est celle d'un noyau dur de
militants qui sont devenus beaucoup plus
que des militants il était idolâtré
il est devenu une idole donc ce qu'il
cherche
moi je ne sais pas du tout si se
présentera ou s'il poussera sa fille
tout ça c'est spéculatifs et je
n'entrerai pas là dedans mais ce que je
crois profondément c'est qu'il a une
stratégie extrêmement précises
concernant le parti républicain il faut
battre le fer quand il est chaud le
parti républicain et tenaillés entre
ceux qui veulent lâcher trump et passer
à autre chose et ce qui reste
majoritaire qui veulent rester alignés
derrière trump je répète ils restent
majoritaires il profite de cela pour il
l'a dit d'ailleurs l'extrait que vous
nous avez un diffuser tout à fait clair
et net là dessus il veut absolument
empêcher le parti républicain de ceux
des trains pisé de manière à laisser
toutes les portes ouvertes pour la
prochaine mais quitte à faire imploser
le parti alors quitte à faire imploser
le parti mais c'est déjà le cas en
partie puisque on le voit bien il ya des
micros dissidence chez les républicains
mais encore une fois la grande masse
reste trump heist et pour trump train
peas et le parti républicain et
confondre le fait d'être républicain
conservateur et le fait d'être en piste
c'est un objectif essentiel or il n'est
pas dans les gènes du parti républicain
du grand old party de rester aligner
dernier un homme de cette manière là
l'idolâtrie ne fait pas partie du camp
républicain
quoi qu'on passe des conservateurs
américains et on s'arrêtera sur ces mots
parlera de la birmanie une prochaine
fois ça faisait partie des thèmes prévus
mais on n'a pas eu le temps d'autres
étaient passionnants ce soir merci en
tout cas d'y avoir participé c'est la
fin de cette émission se retrouvent
demain exceptionnellement à 22h30
seulement
en attendant vous retrouvez bonjour chez
vous dès 7h30 au rayonnement de chimie
recevra notamment cyril chabagny et le
président de la cftc souhaite une
excellente soirée sur lui
[Musique]